Ja, ich weiß nicht, ja wohl.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Takye Mezoğlu.
Ich bin hier der zuständige Arzt.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden.
Sind Sie damit alle verstanden?
Ja, das ist Ihnen auch. Bitte schön.
Ah ah.
Zuerst gehe ich heißen Sie.
Mein Name ist Frau Yvonne Steffens.
Frau Steffens, können Sie bitte Ihren Namen umbuchen?
Mein Vornamen ist Yvonne, das ist Y.
Vogelfrauen, Otto, Notol, Notol, Emil.
Otto und?
Und?
Notol, Notol, also N, N.
Und dann am Ende ein E, Emil.
Okay. Yvonne.
Okay.
Und Nachnamen?
Mein Nachname ist Steffens.
Ist T, Emil, 2 mal F.
Emil, Notol, Siegfried.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Steffens?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. Juni 1996.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel liegen Sie?
Ich bin circa 1,62 m und wiege aktuell 65 kg.
Ja, ui.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe 3 Kinder, ja.
Okay.
Frau Steffens, was für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, schön, dass Sie Zeit haben.
Ich habe seit gestern zunehmende Luftnotes.
Ich habe die Zeit, die ich habe,
die ich in der Luft zu schmelzen.
die ich schmelzen kann.
Ich habe die Zeit, die ich habe, die ich schmelzen kann.
Wenn ich einatme, wenn ich versuche, tief einatmen,
dann blockiert das und dann kann ich nicht mehr atmen.
Es ist schwer, Luft zu bekommen.
Hallo.
Hallo, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ja.
Da sind Sie.
Ich habe jetzt nichts von Ihnen mehr.
Hallo.
So, jetzt ist besser.
Ja, ich höre Sie jetzt.
Aber ich glaube, die Verbindung ist im Moment ganz schlecht.
Das ist besser.
Es könnte sein.
Jetzt können Sie mich gut hören.
Jetzt ist gut, ja.
Dann machen wir weiter, okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Also wie gesagt, sobald ich anfange zu laufen,
auch in der Wohnung, wird die Luft immer ganz knapp.
Dann versuche ich etwas tief zu atmen, aber das blockiert.
Ich kann nicht mehr tief atmen.
Aber ich merke auch seit einigen Tagen, dass die Luft sehr schlecht ist.
Ja, sehr schlecht.
Ja, also das Hauptproblem ist die Luft.
Okay.
Also Luftprobleme haben Sie seit gestern oder seit einigen Tagen?
Seit einigen Tagen, ja.
Ja, das stimmt.
Haben Sie Husten?
Manchmal ja.
Wenn ich mich anstrengen, dann muss ich auch mit das Husten.
Das stimmt.
Trockener Husten oder mit Auswurf?
Es ist ein trockener Husten.
Ja.
Okay.
Schmerzen in Ihrem Brust?
Nein, das ist hier auf der linken Seite.
Wenn ich drauf drücke, dann tut es auch manchmal weh.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Es ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Manchmal kommt es ganz plötzlich und ist sehr stark.
Das geht bis vielleicht 7, 8.
Manchmal ist es nur 1 bis 3.
Wie?
Okay.
Wow.
Entschuldigung?
Haben Sie auch Herzrasen oder Herzschmerzen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ein Herzrasen habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Wow.
Haben Sie solche Beschwerden vorher?
Das ist das erste Mal.
Hab ich früher noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Möchten Sie etwas zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden hinzufügen?
Ja.
Ich habe noch viele andere Erkrankungen.
Aber das ist mein Hauptproblem.
Ja.
Jetzt möchte ich nach Ihrer Krankengeschichte ein paar Fragen stellen.
Leiden Sie etwas vor Erkrankungen?
Wie zum Beispiel Blutdruck oder Zucker?
Blutdruck habe ich nicht.
Blutzucker auf.
Blutzucker auch nicht.
Aber ich habe seit 5 Jahren ein Brustkrebs.
Da musste mir die linke Brust operiert werden.
Die ist komplett entfernt worden.
Okay.
Ich habe danach eine Chemotherapie und eine Bestrahlung gehabt.
Das war vor circa 5 Jahren.
Vor 2 Jahren ist mir auch die restliche Erkrankungen
entfernt worden.
Da hat man auch Krebs festgestellt.
Seit einem Jahr hat man eine neue Therapie begonnen.
Auch mit Chemotherapie.
Die war bis letzter Woche.
Bis letzter Woche haben Sie wieder Chemotherapie
und Strahlentherapie begonnen?
Nein.
Ich habe hier ein paar Fragen.
Ich habe hier eine Strahlentherapie begonnen.
Nein, ich habe hier eine Strahlentherapie begonnen.
Das war vorher bei der ersten Operation.
Jetzt habe ich nur eine Chemotherapie begonnen.
Vor einem Jahr, bevor man die Chemotherapie begonnen hat,
habe ich einen Port bekommen.
Hier oben.
Entschuldigung.
Oben welche Seite? Links oder rechts?
Links oben habe ich einen Port.
Ich bekomme seit einem halben Jahr
auch Ernährung und Infusionen über den Port.
Ich war sehr, sehr schlank.
Ich hatte sehr viel Gewicht abgenommen.
Ich war zuletzt
ca. 40 kg.
Jetzt mit der Ernährung über den Port
und mit der Chemotherapie habe ich wieder etwas erzielt.
Ich habe wieder etwas angewicht zugenommen.
Jetzt habe ich ca. 65 kg.
Sie sehen, ich habe hier einen kleinen Schlau.
Das ist meine Morphinpumpe.
Okay.
Meine Morphinpumpe.
Darüber kann ich dann selbst steuern
und die Schmerzen
entsprechend regeln.
Ich habe noch eine Erkrankung.
Ich glaube, das ist genug.
Im Moment nicht.
Ich habe gemeint,
wesentliche Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Außer diese zwei Operationen
sind Sie auch operiert worden?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe vor zwei Monaten Probleme
mit dem Wasserlassen gekonnt.
Da hat man festgestellt,
dass ich einen Nierenaufstau
auf der rechten Seite habe.
Da musste mir eine Schiene legen.
Eine Dopplio-Schiene.
In die Nähe.
Ich habe ein Wasserlassen.
Nein, da habe ich noch eine.
Nein, hier habe ich noch eine.
Frau Steff, hast du ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch,
und mein Vater ist vor drei Jahren verstorben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wissen Sie genau,
Ist der Vater gestorben?
Er hatte leider einen Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt?
Okay.
Ist jede Mutter gesund?
Meine Mutter hat einen hohen Blutdruck und auch Diabetes.
Sie hat da Medikamente, aber ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, aber die wird sich jetzt auch untersuchen lassen wegen der Brust,
ob sie da auch, weil sie wieder eine kleine Knoten getastet hat.
Aber bisher war sie gesund, ja.
Okay.
Und sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Die Kinder sind gesund, sie haben keine Probleme, wirklich.
Ja, weiß nicht.
Und wann war Ihre erste und letzte Monatsblutung?
Aufgrund der Chemotherapie ist es völlig durcheinandergekommen.
Also ich habe seit halb Jahren keine Monatsblutung.
Wann war die erste?
Wie erste Blutung? Wie meinen Sie das?
Ihre erste Regenmesische Monatsblutung, erste Periode.
Als Kind meint sie, oder als Kind.
Ach so, auch gut.
Sie wollen aber Sachen wissen.
Da war ich, glaube ich, zwölf Jahre alt.
Okay.
Und wann war Ihr letzte Fraunhaarsbesuch?
Ja, ich bin ständig beim Fraunhaars wegen der Brust.
Also das war jetzt vor zwei Wochen.
Und war alles in Ordnung?
Ja, Sie haben auch zweite OP gehabt und Chemotherapie bekommen.
Und die Kontrolle war gut, oder?
War so weit okay.
Und haben Sie außer Ihrem Brustkrebs andere geneakologische Probleme?
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Frau Steffens, haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie Fieber gehabt?
Ja, das im Rahmen der Chemotherapie immer wieder mal.
Das waren dann Hanwix-Infekte.
Da habe ich dann Antibiotika bekommen, aber jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht.
Okay.
Was auch fällt, ist, dass ich seit circa einer Woche so Oedeme an den Beinen habe.
Das wird immer mehr und das Spand auch ganz kräftig.
Okay, in den beiden Beinen, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Ein bisschen, ja. Es spandet. Das tut auch manchmal weh.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchschlafen?
Ja, immer.
Also seitdem ich jetzt die erste Brust operiert bekommen habe,
habe ich eigentlich chronische Schlafstufe.
Ist der Apetit gut?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Deswegen habe ich ja den Portia bekommen, damit ich ein bisschen Ernährung bekomme.
Das ist immer noch sehr schlechte Apetite.
Ich habe kein Hungergefühl und ich möchte auch nichts essen.
Das ist eigentlich immer so langen schon so.
Also im Moment erneiden Sie sich über den Port, oder?
Ja, ich esse immer noch ganz wenig und ich kann auch wenig trinken.
Überwiegend wird es über den Port gemacht, die Ernährung.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang?
Ja, das ist extrem schwierig.
Oft habe ich Verstockungen und da muss ich nachhelfen.
Ich muss Abschwemmungen nehmen.
Oft habe ich auch viel Luft im Bauch und das tut auch immer weh.
Das ist immer schwierig, seitdem ich wieder die Chemotherapie habe.
Okay, Frau Steffens, gibt es noch etwas, was Sie seelisch belastet?
Ja gut, also im Moment ist das jetzt genug, aber ich hatte früher noch andere Probleme mit dem Wetter geworden.
Aber im Moment ist das jetzt mit der Luft das Hauptproblem.
Nehmen Sie Regen, wie sich dabei bedarf, Medikamente ein?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe wie gesagt die Morphinpumpe, die ich immer brauche.
Ich habe Wassertabletten, da nehme ich eine am Morgen die Thorase mit.
Dann habe ich gegen die Übelkeit Medikamente das MCP und ich nehme zusätzlich noch Paracetamol, wenn ich möchte.
Können Sie sich an die Dosierung nehmen?
Das weiß ich nicht, das wird immer aufgefüllt von den Schwesteren.
Das ist eine Flasche und das reicht meistens für 3 Tage.
Aber die Säle drin ist weiß.
Okay, und Thorase mit morgens, wie viel Milligramm?
10 Milligramm.
MCP?
Je nachdem, wie stark die Übelkeit ist, nehme ich bis zu 3 Tabletten am Tag.
Und Paracetamol?
Das ist immer unterschiedlich, dann nehme ich eine oder zwei Tabletten, wenn nötig, gleichzeitig.
Okay, und rauchen Sie, Frau Stephens?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Drogen, Morphin ist doch droge genug.
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, gegen Antibiotika habe ich eine Allergie, Pinzillin.
Pinzillin?
Wie ausstatt ich die Allergie?
Ich bekomme so einen Ausschlag, so einen roten Ausschlag am ganzen Körper.
Und ich bekomme dann auch einen sehr starken Yukreiz, auch Luftnot, das habe ich manchmal gehabt.
Deswegen vermeide ich Pinzillin.
Was meinen Sie, woher die Luftnot kommt? Was ist das Problem?
Oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, jetzt wollte ich das sagen eigentlich.
Jetzt darf ich mir sagen, okay.
Jetzt bin ich mit den Fragen fertig.
Ob Sie etwas hinzubehen oder fragen?
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor. Sie haben sich viel Zeit genommen, aber ich, die Luftnot macht mir Probleme.
Wenn Sie mir da helfen können, werde ich Ihnen sehr dankbar.
Natürlich werden wir Ihnen helfen.
Aber es ist zu früh, Frau Stephens, etwas Konkretes zu sagen.
Ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Ihnen Gerült abnehmen.
Und dann, ich veranlasse für Sie eine Röntgenaufnahme von Ihrem Brust.
Und ein EKG.
Und dann können wir genauer besprechen.
Okay.
Gut, vielen Dank. Machen Sie auch einen Unterschein?
Nach der Röntgenaufnahme können wir eventuell auch einen Unterschein machen.
Okay.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Dann bedanke ich mich und dann sehen wir weiter.
Danke auch.
Jetzt können Sie Ihren Martinswürfel lesen.
Und dann gleich bei Ihnen.
Okay, dann machen wir die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Ja, okay.
Und danach sprechen wir über die Möglichkeiten, dass Sie sein können.
Ja.
Haben in der Zwischenzeit vielleicht die anderen Kolleginnen Fragen?
Ja, natürlich.
Wir lesen mal kurz die Relotizen.
Ja.
Okay.
Sollen wir weiter machen?
Ja, okay.
Kollege, dann erzählen Sie mal.
Okay.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag, Herr Kollege.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Die Patientin heißt Yvonne Stevens.
Sie ist 38 Jahre alt.
Sie ist eine Lehrerin von Beruf, verheiratet und hat drei Kinder.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen seit ein paar Tagen bestehende Dispene
und Torkatschmerzen auf der linken Seite.
Die Dispene und Schmerzen sind belastungsabhängig,
sagt die Patientin.
Und manchmal hat sie auch trockenes Pluses.
Und sie bewertet die Schmerzintensität unterschiedlich,
wenn die Schmerzen so stark ist,
sieben bis acht Prozent sehen auf der Schmerzkala.
Aber wenn sie leicht sind, eins bis zwei,
die Schmerzen strahlen nirgendwo hinaus.
Und die Fragen nach Takyukardii oder Extrasystole wurden verneint.
Als wesentliche Vorerkrankungen,
da war sie unter Mama-Karcinom.
Vor fünf Jahren hatte sie Mama-Karcinom links.
Und die linke Mama wurde entfernt.
Dann hat sie Chemotherapie und Radioterapie bekommen.
Vor zwei Jahren wurde Mama-Karcinom rechts auch festgestellt
und auch operiert.
Und bis vor einer Woche hat sie wieder Chemotherapie bekommen.
Vor einem Jahr hat sie einen Port auf der rechten Seite,
auf der rechten Torokale Region bekommen.
Seit sechs Monaten erneut sie sich fast nur über den Port.
Parenteral, ja.
Sie bekommt seit sechs Monaten, seit einem halben Jahr,
eine Parenteralernährung.
Und vor zwei Monaten hat sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Sie hat ein Stand in den rechten Nieren bekommen.
Die Familie ist vor drei Jahren an die Mjokardinfahrt verstorben.
Die Mutter leidet an Arterelle Hypertonien und Arthymethylethus.
Und bei Schwester wurden auch Mama-Johnen festgestellt.
Aber das ist noch nicht festgestellt, ob sie gutartig oder malin oder benin sind.
Die günäkologische Anamnese ist unaufgängig.
Und vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig, bis auf seitdem sie Karzinom hatte,
in so einem Nie und alte Obstipation und andere Abdörmung schmerzen.
All das ist unaufgängig.
als Medikamente nimmt sie Morphin in der Pumpe, in den, über den Port.
Und Thorazemid, 10 mg einmal morgens, MCP gegen Nausea, 3 Mal Antag und Parastemol,
1 bis 2 Mal Antag bei Bülow.
Sie gibt keinen Nikotinabusus, keinen Alkoholabusus und keinen Drogenabusus an.
Und bei der Patienten ist eine Pensinallergie bekannt und sie reagiert darauf mit Exantem, Pruritus und Pistone.
Sehr gut. Haben Sie noch weitere Informationen?
Nein, das war es. Und diese Analystie-Bangaben, die er deuten am Hessen auf einen Pneumotorax.
Wie kommt das Pneumotorax?
Die Patientin hat plötzlich auf gezwählte Atemprobleme und sie hat auch einen Port auf der rechten Seite.
Der Port ist rechts, die Schmerzen sind links. Eine Differenzialdiagnose würde ich sagen.
Das würde ich mal so stehen lassen. Ein spontan Pneu würde natürlich viel heftigere reagieren.
Das hat sich aber langsam entwickelt über einige Tage.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie nicht auf dem Pneumotorax hat, aber gut, das ist eine Möglichkeit.
Woran muss man noch denken? Die anderen Kollegen können helfen.
Leude Ergus?
Sehr gut. Ein Plurer Ergus.
Vielleicht eine Hematotorax wegen einer Verletzung durch den Port.
Der Port liegt ja schon über ein Jahr.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass durch den Port eine Ursache vorliegt, ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Das heißt, der Port liegt auf der rechten Seite und der Schlauch vom Port ist immer sehr klein.
Wenn dann bei der Port Anlage zu Beginn der Implantation kann man ein Pneumotorax stechen.
Aber nach einem Jahr? Unwahrscheinlich.
Aber auch daran muss man denken, natürlich, das ist auch eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Aber ich würde als erstes an eine Plurer Ergus denken.
Das kann man mit einem Ultraschall sehr leicht und sofort sehen.
Die Patienten, die ich jetzt vorgestellt habe, hat einen Plurer Ergus.
Auf der linken Seite, und zwar einen großen Plurer Ergus.
Woran muss man dann denken, wenn diese Patientin ein Plurer Ergus auf der einen Seite hat?
Metastasierung?
Ja gut. Das heißt, man würde den Plurer punktieren, diesen Ergus einschicken und pathologisch untersuchen lassen.
Auf dort mal legende Zellen drinnen. Sehr gut. Also ein Punkt.
Genau, also Plurer Ergus.
Plurmotorax, kann immer wieder auftreten natürlich.
Was machen Sie mit den Schmerzen? Die hat links Torbenkahl an den Rippen Schmerzen gehabt.
Woran muss man denken?
Yokardinfarkt.
Natürlich.
Ein Herz muss man denken, das ist wichtig.
Das heißt, ich muss auch das Herz mehr angucken. Zum einen, ob sie einen Yokardinfarkt hat.
Zweitens, sie hat Oedema in den Beinen, woran denke ich dann?
Und sie hat Chemotherapie.
Was kann mit dem Herzen passieren im Rahmen einer Chemotherapie?
Herzinsuffizienz.
Ja gut, genau. Es kann sein, dass sie jetzt eine Herzschwäche entwickelt hat.
Und das macht sich jetzt mit der Luftnot bemerkbar.
Sehr gut. Also ich mache auch ein Ultraschall vom Herzen.
Röntgen haben sie schon gemacht.
Da sehe ich, ob sie ein großes Herz hat, ob sie eine zentrale Staun auf der Lunge hat zum Beispiel.
Sehr gut. Also ob daran muss ich denken.
Aber das hat sie nicht.
Diese Oedema an den Beinen, denke ich, kommt über die Ernährung, die parenterale Ernährung.
Das ist meine Vermutung, weil sie viel Eiweiß bekommt.
Sie war untergewichtig.
Und man hat ihr viel Eiweiß und Fett gegeben.
Sie ist von 40 Kilo auf 65 Kilo angestiegen.
Ich denke, dass das einfach durch diese ÖD und durch diese Protein,
wahrscheinlich und durch die Ernährung, ist aber auch sicherlich durch die Grunderkrankung.
Woran denke ich noch? Stechende Schmerzen an den Rippen.
Woran muss man noch denken? Zwei Sachen fehlen mir.
Auch Knochen mit Testasierung?
Zum Beispiel. Testasierung, genau.
Ganz einfache Sache.
Eine Pleuritis.
Sie hat ja eine Bestrahlung gehabt auf der linken Seite, das liegt länger zurück.
Die Bestrahlung kann natürlich die Pleurinfinklich sein.
Und jetzt sich noch mal reizen.
Dazu eine Pleuritis, das kann sehr schmerzhaft sein.
Und eine Interkostalneurologie.
Eine ganz einfache Sache, dass die Nerven zwischen den Rippen gereizt sind
durch Verspannung der Rückennmuskulatur.
Ganz einfache Sache.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Das war sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Es tut mir leid wegen unserem kleinen Gast.
Er hat uns ein bisschen gestört, aber das war doch glaube ich schon ganz gut.
Er wollte mit der Anprägen.
TBC, ja, muss man daran denken, aber ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Die Patientin hat ja schon diverse Untersuchungen vorher.
Das ist jung, kann schon sein.
Bei Patientinnen, die aus dem asiatischen Bereich kommen, also aus Russland
oder Kriegisäen usw. oder aus Indien, da muss man natürlich auch mal
an eine TBC denken, auch bei jungen Menschen, aber ist jetzt bei der
EU wahrscheinlich, da ist das Problem mit der Mamakatsin um.
So, haben die anderen Kollegen, Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Im Moment keine.
Herr Doktor, ich danke recht herzlich.
Das war sehr gut.
Weil ist Ihre Prüfung?
Am 16. Januar.
Vielen Dank.
Vielen Erfolg, es wird Ihnen schon machen, das ist gut, das ist ja schön.
Was sind Sie für ein Facharzt?
Ich bin kein Facharzt.
Noch nicht.
Das wird Ihnen schon machen.
Okay, dann wünsche ich Ihnen allen ein schönes Wochenende,
ein schönen Abend und alles Gute.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Das war Robert Schander.